[Applause]
things got heated when 3 6 mafia and
bone thugs in harmony faced off in the
latest versus matchup
[Music]
it all went down on thursday when the
legendary rap groups took the stage at
the hollywood palladium in l.a it keeps
you on your toes and things were tense
from the jump when the night's host fat
joe kicked things off with a coin toss
to decide who would go last
do you want heads or tails so you pick
tails
i hope i catch this
hold up
[Music]
tails it is
3-6 mafia performed their 2000 classic
who run it
[Applause]
[Music]
and bone thugs in harmony responded with
their 1994 hit no surrender which had
the sold out crowd up on their feet
but things came to a head after
performing buddha levels when busy bone
called 36 mafia out claiming they
disrespected him while he was performing
hey hey before we even get started
you ugly [ __ ] ain't gonna be
mocking me while i'm on mother's stage
like straight
up
[Music]
security put the whole show on pause
while they tried to calm things down and
eventually busy bone came back on stage
to address the situation i want to
apologize to everybody out there
on both sides
[Music]
i'm not trying to
and versus is exactly that a party i was
so excited about it when e.t chatted
with fat joe back in october shortly
after his own versus battle against ja
rule at madison square garden in new
york city he opened up about being a
part of the experience now i got to ask
you you were on verses recently how was
that experience for you oh man that
thing was like a prize fight jahru's my
brother one of my best friends so i'm
glad i did it with him but it was
nothing like it it was a beautiful
feeling but back to bone thugs versus
3-6 mafia lil wayne chamillionaire and
lil john all made surprise appearances
and get this the night ended with both
groups hugging it out and teaming up for
a joint performance of bone thugs in
harmony's 1996 track the crossroads
[Music]
[Applause]
so what did the fans think hey
three six mafia
phone
got me over here
well real housewives of atlanta star
candy burris was loving it and shared
clips of her rocking out to the show all
night long on her insta story
3 6 5
they showing up okay
if y'all not watching the live on versus
tv
y'all miss me
lebron james was also all about it
tweeting quote i love bone and three six
bumped both of them growing up and still
do actually so who will face off next
we'll just have to wait and see but that
joe previously told et who he'd like to
see battle it out you've said everyone
is scared to go up against buster rhymes
do you know busta rhymes is the greatest
entertainer in hip-hop like you're done
like you're cooked you go against busta
rhyme jeff cook do you think anyone has
what it takes to go up against him
the one person i think
should have went against busty moms it's
ludacris and ludacris already win
against nelly so um can do it again yeah
if he could do it again that that would
be it or missy it's going to be hard for
buster to find an opponent
you